time's up rejection will tell us about
randomized preconditioning dr. micha and
thank you for inviting me and organize
those organizing this so I'm going to
talk about solving canonical correlation
analysis or explain what that is but in
general the technique I'm going to
present is relevant in general when you
have quadratic equality concerned but to
keep since concrete will mainly discuss
CCA and we want to use randomized
recognition so I will start with some
background and motivation for what what
I'm going to do and then go into the
victors so there's basically two
approaches to leverage randomization
when you're talking about numerical
linear algebra there is the original
technique of sketching solve the one
that came in in the first paper it's by
Michael morning practicing as well this
the idea is to you have a program and
this is done in kind of rough rough
lines it's not big you know there are
variants from this technique but in
general you have an input you sketch the
input you use that to form a smaller
problem you solve the problem exactly
and then you office you use that
solution to form a solution to the
original problem and try to reason about
how good that solution is another
technique which feels less in the
literature is the idea of sketch to
precondition you take this sketch the
input like in the sketch and solve but
now you don't solve a new problem but
you go back to the original problem and
somehow views the sketch to accelerate
the solution of the original problem
mainly as a pre-conditioner in some
iterative method
let's look at an example a very simple
example overdetermined least-squares
sketches of a porch we'll start with you
have an input and input be you will
sketch them you'll multiply them by a
random sketching matrix s the sketch
matrix can be a sampling matrix it can
be a fast randomizer demand matrix
there's more than one ways to do this
sketch but you do it both on a and on B
and that gives you an OOP a new program
that you just solve you can solve it
easily use in qrow SVD you pick your
favorite method and it gives you a way
that y is the same size as Dec so it's a
valid candidate solution for the origin
of them so you return that solution and
you can reason how good that is if you
select the sketch in matrix correctly
and you have enough force you not
metrics you can reason about this
solution you're not going to go two
digits on this nice statue pair to
recognition approach works slightly
different you still sketch the make the
a matrix two for me but you don't sketch
the right hand side don't sketch B the
vector B so now you want to use B to
accelerate the solution of the original
program the way to do that
there's more than one way to do it but
one way to do it is to now form a cure
factorization of B gives you an
orthonormal basis which you don't you
discard and an upper triangular matrix R
which you now uses a pre-conditioner in
an iterative method specifically I wrote
using a rescue are but you can use a
director at your method but the idea is
that you solve this original form ax
minus B using an iterative method and
use the R as a precondition they are was
built using the sketch
so each approach has its advantages for
the sketch and solve I mean this is the
kind of the feature then there's the
advantage and disadvantages
so the sketches off watch if you do if
you use the sketch incorrectly and you
design your algorithm you know in a good
way
then you'll get I success right but the
dependency on there on the accuracy
which again depends on the specific
power you want to use but you know if
you want epsilon accuracy whatever it
means for that specific problem your
defenses is polynomial but you're not
going to do not go into the integration
so that gives you a chance of doing
something like streaming or anything
that passes only one time or few times
over the day so the advantage is that
because there is no iteration and you
and you're basically just going over the
data sketching the data and walking out
it's very fast and the running time is
deterministic but since you're
phenomenal depends on the accuracy you
only get cuda good accuracy good
accuracy and it's a Monte Carlo
algorithm we get a solution don't really
know if it's a good solution you hope it
you have an app ability it is a good
solution but you don't know it is a good
solution generally in in data science
application this could approximation is
fine and this this is good and that's
why we are you know there's a workshop
on randomized American linear algebra
for the schedule and to finish up what
you also have Ike success rate but now
the success rate is usually not on the
on the quality of the solution but
rather on the running time you know you
or you're solving the problem good
accuracy but you only knew the only
reason about its running time when you
have an exponential accuracy dependence
like low 1 over epsilon so you are going
to get you are able to get very accurate
solutions if you need them but you're
going to do iterations so the advantage
is that you can get very high accuracy
and when you are successful you have a
good solution but it's generally slower
than the sketch and solve approach I
mean at least if you're if you are
willing to go is critical so if you want
AI accuracy the sketch and so approach
will not
and you have to do iterations so we have
a point of history
so which approach is better really it
depends on what you want on our accurate
you want the solution and how much we
are willing to pay can you make multiple
passes so that they type I'm not going
to go into it which one is better
my point is that each one of them it can
be useful and we won't basically both
but if you look at the literature
there's a lot of method on the sketch
and solve I have a list here of
certainty of polos that people have
suggested over the years a sketching
solve approach to the Dropbox you made
them and it's not an exhaustive list but
if you look at the stage to recognition
there's some work on that but it's
mainly of regression algorithms like
linear regression solving linear
equations or ordinary education
vizor that you can caramelize it that's
been recently suggested does of course
all the work with laplacian solvers
that's for square matrices
there is even some walk on so
neurological structure whether user on
domination and even linear system with
stencils try products are but still it's
mainly solving linear equations and this
is essentially and exertive list not
most of the methods that are on this
side don't have that sketch the
precondition of course
and the question that kind of motivated
my walk here is can randomize
speculation be used beyond regression
not just for some aggression followed by
associate follows that are not of this
regression structure that that gets you
on
turreted method I tell ative linear
solver or
in solution so this is this the
executive summary of what I'm going to
present and I'll go into the details I'm
going to discuss a randomized
recognition approach for canonical
correlation analysis like I said in the
first slide it can't be applied more
generally to when you have a room with
quadratic equality constraints the basic
idea is to use some technique called
Romanian optimization the canonical
correlation analysis is basically a
problem on which are just concerned that
on a manifold so when you want to solve
it you need to use you can do it
multiple ways one way to do it is to use
a mini optimization and on top of that
we are sketching to get our technique
and the key observation that we use to
do that
is that like a said CCA's optimization
or money for consent I'm going to
explain what you see in the next slide
when you do a million optimization you
need to set a manifold and impose a
metric on that manifold and the way you
select the metric matters to the
convergence of the algorithm you want to
use a specific metric but using it is
expensive like like we would like in the
case of Sonia equation so you can use
sketching to approximate the metric you
want to use and then get fast
convergence but without paying the price
of of using the expensive metric that's
the executive summary let's go to the
details so unless you're not everybody's
familiar with CCA so in one slide I'm
going to summarize what this technique
is so it's it's a linear algebra problem
but as a statistical motivation you
basically have observeit you have 200
wearables and you want to find how you
can rotate them so that there will be a
collation we maximized so you want me to
do that
one way to do
oxi CA does that is that you take it off
you put your data in to data metric six
x and y both of them have an observation
deck size G sub X features and y r-d
survived features and you select some
regularization parameter which can be 0
then basically you want to find the
vectors that will be linear combination
of the features so that between the two
one bubbles the correlation we maximize
the correction is just the dot product
of the transformed data so you taught
some Y by multiplying by V to some X by
x oh and now you want the correlation to
be maximized so I'm going to only
discuss finding the top correlation
there's ways to generalize the problem
CCA to having more below more
correlations but we are going to focus
on finding the largest correlation but
of course just maximizing this can you
can write that to infinity so you need
to impose some constraint and the
constraint is that that data imposes the
following that basically your you have
to be on on the sphere in use by the X
transpose X and you put that you post
this on the use and and
corresponding constraint on them on
their face and we're in a regulation
setting you regularize these raw
matrices and if lambda is equal to 0
that's what you recall in the linear
algebra literature principal angles of
vectors between subspaces and if lambda
is bigger than 0 it's just a regular
observation of that so this is the CCA
problem any questions about that before
I go
see you that's the unit vector and why
me that those are the unit vectors so
the angle is between the spaces of x and
y yes because you want something that's
spanned in the end one something it is
fun facts or something misguided by B so
how do you solve CCA where there is a
direct method the Bjork and Golub
algorithm it's fairly simple you start
by building a qubit orthogonalize in X&Y
you'd walk your factorization you get a
note on a basis QX on the basis qy you
don't they also note that you put it
into both legs and both the kills and
there are two and then you basically
take these two matrices multiply them
and do an SVD and from that SVD you can
find the U and the V that you're looking
for okay I'm not going to do it that's
why this algorithm works this is the
right method that solves this program
and the cost is MV squared
basically so we need to review of both
features in x and y so it's and the X
where plus and B y squared but in
general it's nd square which is pretty
good but again we want to reduce this
dependence the laws of sketching solar
porch and it appeared in a paper by
myself and Christos bacillus you want to
later and an associate associate in 2015
the idea is again it's a very simple
sketch of solve approach you start with
your x and y you sketch them using a
sketch matrix it can be any can be
sampling it can be likewise randomized
at the mouth you just need 12 a subspace
embedding on the x and y that's what you
mean and then once you've reduced the
policies you use the the direct method
bjorgen goal of algorithm to find an
approximate solution and that gives you
an improved dependence on n if you
select the sketchy matrix correctly but
again you have the epsilon to the power
minus 2 dependence they owned accuracy
parameter and your darkest parameter is
that where you approximate
the correlation so we want we want a
basically an IR pre-collision approach
to this problem we know already of a
sketch and so Bob can be preconditioning
for that you need an iterative method so
there are actually an iterative method
suggested by volume Inza in 95
it's basically an alternating least
square approach a very natural approach
well at each point you cut you off what
you'll keep in data rates both say u n
of V and you iterate you want
at one point you fix the V and you opt
in and you improve the use so that
equation we've maximized and then you
and and then you fix the U and u Max and
you optimize you picks the V and you
optima and they fixed the you and you
optimize the field so basically the way
you write it is that you know if when
you want the next few you'll fix the car
in TV and then you've tried to find the
you that will get you as close as
possible to Y times the current V with
the regularization that as actually as a
closed-form solution that involves this
ROM matrices so you have this grommet
recess and you want to write this like
this but then the solution is this but
this moves you outside your concern so
you need to to enforce the code side by
projecting back to the constraint set
and now you do the same when u is fixed
and and you optimize the V so there is
this algorithm actually in the original
paper I don't think the out any result
but on any result and the convergence
right but recently in 2016 there was an
analysis that showed that this has
exponential convergence in the condition
number that determines how fast it
converges depends on day on the gap on
the gap between the largest canonical
Croatia and next largest general
corrosion didn't really define what is
the second largest but there is a
definition of the second largest and and
of course you have dependence on the gap
this is
because canonical Croatian is
essentially and I get a generalized
eigenvalue program you expect to see
these dependence on the eigen gap okay
so there's this result seems you know
that we are we are up here an iterative
resort it has exponential convergence
what's the Poland the problem is that
how do we solve this porn so we can have
we have this explicit solution we can
use that but if we look at the solution
it involves the inverse of this dramatic
so of course you're not going to form
the inverse we are going to do watch
rescue factorization of these positive
definite matrix but even to do this us
infrared directly photo is action you
need to form the Sigma xx matrix now if
we form the Sigma X six matrix that's
and end this quelled operation so what
did you gain you have the direct method
the door does a QR factorization of the
X and a QR factorization of Y that
already does nd square but now we are
going at the first step do an ND squared
operation so obviously you are not going
to sell by which saved anything by using
an iterative mastery so another approach
is to view this as regression I try to
solve this approximately that's true so
these guys were okay so there is these
guys what they did they actually try
they solve this regression use it fast
code and descent but then there are the
dependence on the condition number of X
and so one thing you could try to do is
try to use kind of read regression
solver on this X yeah you have that if
you're not precondition this but you can
try to precondition deal
you can certainly in every iteration you
are going to solve to read regression
cordoning of that is
and all the conditioning of eggs you
don't get away from it in the end no you
do get away from me you do get away
because you inform us your form of
sketch effects and and you could do I
don't think we have support because you
are going to do iterations to find a
solution
I just think III that will work I just
think I'm going to present a whether
that will work better so yeah you can do
that but I think what will happen is
that you'll have to solve your song
you'll spend too much iteration in this
in addition we want to avoid this inner
literature we don't want to have an
outer iteration like this and an inter
iteration that I like this we want to
want it one method
okay that's repeating what I said area
so that the set up time is nd square but
then every durations when we finish the
set up every iteration takes until it's
just one pass of the matrix and the
number of iteration is as the concerned
defendant so so in one aspect we are
very happy we have a very good iteration
complexity and the iteration courses
it's fine but our best our problem is
with the set of time it's too large it's
as expensive as a direct method okay but
the key observations that I'm going to
use is actually that these are good in
wallets with sweeteners are not in an
least square it's actually a Romanian
gradient descent are good your money at
work to run your dessert so again I need
to give you some what with what I mean
by that
so this is the one slide back on
something that cannot be described in
one slide or one talk but I need to give
some back on so basically in Romanian
optimization Romanian optimization we
want to solve problems the following
four we want to minimize some function
subject to I could say that they found
that the vector belongs to some smooth
manifold so your graphically trying to
illustrate I believe this is the
manifold over here it locally looks like
Euclidean but it's not Euclidean so you
want to do iterate so we want so we have
to stay on the money for that all time
so there's various ways to do that you
can generalize most optimization method
for me from the Euclidean setting to the
romanian setting
one of the simplest is gradient descent
so what are you doing gradient descent
in the Euclidean setting you take your
point you find a gradient you progress
along the gradient you do you add you
take the negative Lagrangian multiplied
by step size and add it you cannot
really do that in the Romanian case
because the gradient now is some vector
in the tangent space which is a linear
space so if at your current iterate
there is a tangent space at that point
inside that tangent space every every
every vector is tangent to the manifold
it's a way to it's a direction on the
manifold that is locally but if you were
if you take the vector and just add it
up that's going to get you outside the
manifold so what you do to get back to
the manifold is some operation that's
called a retraction to get you back to
the manifold one way to do this is
actually to move along the geodesic in
the direction of of the vector but
that's an expensive operation so there
there was there was a construct called a
retraction which are locally
approximated or dezik
and lets you move around alone day to us
steps in the direction of the gradient
so now but also the gradient what is the
gradient now we are the gradient is is
no longer what's clear what what that
means it's it's now we only have tangent
vector vectors in the tangent space so
there is the Romanian gradient which is
noted here by garage and it really
depends on a manifold but what's crucial
it doesn't only depend on the manifold
but it also depends on how you measure
the dot products in this tangent space
on the Romanian matrix so the money for
this was manifold which is your
constraint you impose on that a romanian
matrix that turns it into our money and
manifold that gives you the notion of
gradient because the National Gallery's
thing is is that is a tangent vector
that makes you the most progress toward
minimizing maximize minimize the
function so take this Romanian gradient
you multiply by step size but now to do
the step you no longer just add you do
this operation of reduction
it's what's important in this slide is
that this Romanian gradient the
direction you want to progress it really
depends on the medics choice you can you
can choose pneumatics multiple ways and
each one will define a different
gradient and there and if you if you
choose this correctly your your method
will converge faster base ok so you can
you can write alternately squares
Romanian steepest descent the function
is just the optimization of light remote
earlier if you look at the constraints
there is basically a manifold domain
it's basically deported manifold off to
general stifle manifolds they're the
projection operation that we took we
took a step and we project it back to
the court straight that's exactly one of
the retraction that is used on that
manifold one of the most popular
attraction and and again the steps that
we are taking this is the formulas for
the stair this is this is the this is if
you stack the step size correctly then
putting this formula gives you back the
ALS they are exactly there in the
Romanian gradient that corresponds to
this matrix this matrix is the manual
matrix that involve the Sigma x axis and
Sigma Y lives so this is an old Romanian
stupid descent what's important here
that we selected this metric this gives
you the gradient and this gave us the
algorithm this on one side gave us the
good iteration complexity made a mess of
converge fast but on the other one
because we we have the Sigma X X and
Sigma Y Wives here in the Matic then the
inverse pop up in the green Romanian
gradient that what causes the I cause
for every step so this is a common
metric usually when you people are doing
optimization on generalized stifle
manifolds they are going to use this
metric I mean usually do use only one
mind for the other put up to which
manifold but this is the Romanian my
metric on the first on this manifold
this is the natural Romanian metric on
this manifold this is naturally
money-market on this manifold and that
addendum is the nut is the most natural
thing to do and that gives this gives a
good convergence bode but it's but you
know but it causes the expenses settle
down so what can we do we can just try
to replace this matrix I think makes X
and Sigma Y with some approximations
that are cheaper to solve so basically
now instead of Sigma X X and Sigma YY we
use em XX m my one those are any
matrices that we form we are going to
use sketchy metrics to form them and
then you need to update your Romanian
gradient you get this bit annoying
formula but that's the formula you get
but what's important about it it doesn't
involve any inverses we sing makes X it
does involve doing a product with Sigma
X 6 but that's fine you multiply by X
and you multiply by X transfer that's an
MD operation but you don't know evolve
in verses of the AMEX X but the MX is
something that you want to solve chip
you're going to form cheaply and then
you just use instead of we are not going
to restrict yourself to gradient descent
you can use line search you can use
Romanian CG
why you receive yourselves to a fixed
step size which is not necessarily best
I'm going to go about this to slide very
quickly basically how do you form the
there this precondition precondition
matrix you could form in any way the way
since we movie are motivated by
sketching we will sketch it technique
one thing is use subsys embedded where
you multiply the x and y by some sketchy
matrix and use that to form MX x MX six
and my Y this is basically the same
strategy that was used in the brain and
wickedly in randomized least squares
solvers another idea is to I'd just
approximate the dominate subspace that
appeal Dena
baby bye-bye Onan and choruses basically
approximately tops
eigenvalue their singular vectors and
use that to form a approximation of the
ground matrix but you do that works only
for visualization and you need to
compensate for the singular vectors that
you in that you ignored and that's only
for lambda bigger than zero so some
preliminary experimental results so we
took them mr. data set and we splitting
it to us just took left part of the
picture right but other people try to
find the correlation between them and we
are plotting the sub optimality in the
objective the economic calculation and
our proximity in the relative error and
we use warm surface artists embedded and
we use romanians VG so so in the x-axis
is the iteration and in y-axis there is
the sub optimality which is this is with
this dominates a special condition which
is this is with a subspace in very
precocious different color correspond to
different choices of their of the
pre-conditioner the bigger the number is
the better the precondition is in
approximating the two Brown matrices so
generally you'll do less situation as a
pre-conditioner is better
also the bit once you you have a very
good pick on if the differences are
pretty small and you do see the
exponential converges this is an annex
in a log scale because you need a small
number
yes I'll switch direction yeah you do
start situation and since you're only
but because you you only need a few it's
very fast if the gap is large that's
true
so the suspects my name is minus n small
but but actually this also works pretty
well it's pretty fast at least for this
nervously just as a baseline if you are
going to use identity petitioners no
precognition
you're going to do 205 iterations so you
considerably save a lot of iterations
here and if you're going to use the
exact inverses what's basically they did
for the base case you're going to do 47
iterations so by using approximation you
already pay anything so you might be
surprised why here we are even doing
evil
less situations in the exact universes
and the answer is that because we formed
a precognition we can do a warm start we
already have a good approximation of the
canonical vectors that comes from their
earlier resorts and from sketches of CCA
so you start in a good place so just
okay I have dined but I'll finish with
this line we can also do second order
methods you can be calculated a romanian
AZ and that's become if the remaining
gradient is is a bit crazy formula that
becomes a completely crazy formula but
you can't compute it and it's sufficient
to compute it and then you can use the
Romanian trust region method that
converges super fast it's super exponent
is super linear convergence but if every
iteration actually solve linear equation
using a relative method so the
iterations are varying cost so here we
made the XS with these products by X and
wine and you see these nice full
versions and also as you are the better
pecan you should generally do less
situation less or that's with X&Y that's
your metric this is how many nd
operations that you have I skip the
parts about the theory and just conclude
some prepared remarks is that randomized
vehicle lineage about chief Sayaka see
my news with precondition in some cases
you do Morton I'm not saying your cases
I agree that in many scenarios for data
science you are happy with the crude
approximation but if you want Aiko I
accuracy you cannot do it with a sketch
and sort of watch you need to use
preconditioning but I occur symbiotic
regression regression method and emanuel
division gives you a way to design those
and the way to do supranational is by
changing a metric and we do it here for
the quadratic equality constraints but
okay we are still this is still the top
that it which is only on
so it also has a quick question and
after that let's go to coffee break
corresponds to no maximization of a
matrix twice the size with zeros on the
diagonal proper and X transpose Y or you
can think of it as a jazz I can value on
that metric but and then you can yeah
yeah that equivalence is known yeah that
equivalence is known but then you can go
doubt or the other word but it's the
same yeah
all right and let's thank time again I'd
use around at the coffee
[Applause]